fortnite has gone back to basics epic
has reinstated the season 5 map that
everyone loves so much along with a
bunch of other classic items and weapons
from those 2018 days as a result the OG
update has amassed over 44 million
players in the first day alone and
that's got a lot of people wondering
should fortnite stay like this
[Music]
forever all right people we have a
second merch drop here at the score
Esports let's have a look guess what
folks our touch grass hoodies did so
well that the suits are actually letting
us make even more dumb gamer inspired
like our new Bader zipup hoodies
made for all the real blue collar
workers out there perfect for any
environment whether it's catching fish
hanging your teammates out to dry or
just tugging on your or how about our
inspiring you onward and forward tea the
ideal shirt for the sweatiest of Gamers
so that you can slam the W key with zero
resistance and little to no chafing
teammates don't like it them ruin
everyone's night oh and yeah we got
these blue Esports te's I forgot we made
these uh yeah they're definitely blue
and they say Esports game in style and
comfort with the store Esports drop 2
available now if you like any of that
check out the link in the description
below for the first time since like 2019
it feels like fortnite is all anyone can
talk about let me take this in
oh my God man got the map what what
we're back we're back I'm getting
chilled I have Goosebumps fortnite
exists in this really odd place despite
continuing to be more popular than
basically any other shooter on the
market it's constantly chasing that
cultural High it had from the late 2010s
yes it's a fact that the game continues
to have Global growth but it's a general
sentiment from the audience that the
game play has gotten a bit too
overwhelming recently fortnite was this
perfect casual game that turned into an
absolute sweatfest where you're getting
on by like 12-year-olds building
skyscrapers in the past you could sit
anyone down to play fortnite and they
would almost immediately grasp it that's
what made the game work so well but as
new updates and Seasons rolled out
things got infinitely more elaborate
making it unappealing for older players
to come back to but the foundations of a
great game were always still there and I
mean who wouldn't want to play a game
where you could be either the
Mandalorian or Patrick Mahomes so it's
my guess that as a way to get players
back epic games sat down and thought to
themselves what is the number one issue
in our community that's stopping people
from playing which is probably why in
March of 2022 they added an official
zero build mode a mode with you guessed
it no building whatsoever and people ate
that up it turns out that simple
was appealing to a lot of players and a
zero build mode was then made permanent
but after more than a year of this how
does fortnite one up themselves well it
turns out by bringing players back to
its most popular ERA last week the devs
released their new season dubbed OG
fortnite returning players back to the
season 5 map from 2018 equipped with all
the fan favorites tilted Towers golf
carts and some classic guns they even
took things a step further by removing
gameplay elements like swimming to truly
immerse players back in those Glory Days
this time epic was banking on both
Simplicity and people's Nostalgia and it
paid off massively in its first day
alone fortnite broke its alltime peak
player account with over 44 million
unique players so you just got 15,000
Subs in two days two days of streaming
hey you better make note on when yeah to
stream these days dude come back come
back come back I got 500 come back I got
500 bro hey uh what the happen boys
however all of this current success
raises a lot of questions one being that
if fortnite is more popular than it's
ever been with its OG map should it stay
like this forever one thing a lot of
people have been pointing out is that
after playing OG fortnite you truly
notice just how much has changed and
yeah it's no secret that over the years
some of these changes have not been too
popular but does that make those changes
a mistake should epic have altered the
game past what made it so popular my gut
answer is to say no obviously for
fortnite to be where it is now it needed
to go through all these Seasons if the
game never changed past 2018 why would
people be coming back now sure if you
look at games like Counter-Strike that
almost never change it might seem like a
good idea to keep things consistent but
that's a bit of an enigma plus fortnite
is a lot more popular than
Counter-Strike ever was even at its peak
and maybe that's because epic is
constantly evolving it if people were
just dropping into the same map with the
same guns year after year maybe the game
dies that being said 44 million players
is a lot of people so what does fortnite
do to keep them from leaving or at least
bring them back more frequently well as
far as the OG fortnite season goes the
road map is to have weekly updates that
bring players to other beloved eras of
the game I think this is a great
decision but what do they do once this
nostalgic chapter ends on December 2nd I
don't think it would be smart to keep
the OG game mode around forever because
you know as they say absence makes the
heart gr fonder but if they go back to
how things were before the update they
risk losing all these older players they
just got back that is unless this OG
update has reinvigorated veteran players
love for the game maybe all they needed
was a reminder and now that they're back
epic can move on to their next ambition
what do you guys think has the OG update
brought you back will you leave once
it's over or do you still after all
these years not understand what the hype
is
about there's these like uh Indie
developers I guess who are making a
Counter-Strike classic offensive I think
it's called and it's CS 1.6 but created
in the csgo source engine there's this
entirely new game that's out that's in a
completely other engine but people want
to go back and play this old one